it's been a long time love Jolin
now let's see
the last time we met I saved your soul
now there's something you can do for me
look I'd love to help but your timing
mister but this won't take long you see
there's a demon eye where its possessing
a little girl not demon he knows your
name
[Music]
this is John Constantine skinny Britnie
trenchcoat I'm gonna clean traced
warlock expert on the occult
they tell you don't like horror movies
[Music]
dammit wall-e bracer I was supposed to
save some of the bad guys for you just a
few you know what I'll make it up to you
first round is on me
no thanks man we're good I actually have
a girl waiting for me next time
accomplished warlock John Constantine at
your service
so let's break this down there's also a
lot of firestorm that I know you guys
are wondering about the big WTF moment
from the episode so I'll say careful for
spoilers from the last episode of
legends of tomorrow just because they're
going through a big roster change and
there's a lot of theories about how they
might fill some gaps a la Wally West so
I'll talk about that during the video
too but because there is so much big
stuff going on I'll say there's a new
round of the flash ring giveaway in this
video announce a winner at the end of
this but you're starting with the
Constantine stuff first because I'm so
happy that he's finally coming on this
show I feel like one of my biggest
problems is isn't the characters that
they're doing the actors are great but I
just feel like they're doing a lot of
sealless characters they need to upgrade
their roster a little bit so when we
heard that Constantine was coming on for
two episode arc a lot of people were
like is this gonna be a trial run will
he come on permanently in a future
season we don't know about that I think
a lot of that just depends on Matt
Ryan's availability and his willingness
to do a season of legends of tomorrow
because it is a big time commitment and
he does a lot of other stuff too I think
he already completed work on the
animated Constantine TV show but they
haven't announced when that's going to
premiere and that's gonna be on the CW
seed it's just like the Vixen animated
TV show but it's just for Constantine
stuff so it'll have all the crazy demon
angels he'll stuff that you would expect
from a Constantine show
is that inviting us yep that would be me
can it make good on its promise oh that
that was a lie it promised me a feast
Constantine and you have delivered what
is this ridiculous thing you five seek
to usurp a land that's rightfully mine I
will stop you consume you body and soul
but as you can tell from Ray's comment
you guys know I don't like horror movies
they're doing in exorcism episode just
like they did with caity lotz way back
during arrow season 4
that's what Constantine was talking
about when he reached out to Sarah for
help you owe me one because I helped
resurrect you and bind your soul back to
your body probably one of the best guest
appearances that arrow has had if you
don't remember that season 4 episode 5
this next episode of legends is called
daddy darkest so obviously it's all
about damian darhk-- in addition to all
this Constantine stuff that's going on
but I think we can assume that even
though he's just here initially to save
this little girl from the demon that's
possessing her he'll also help out with
their malice problem because
supernatural threat reads a lot like a
Constantine villain so we'll see what
advice he has for them malice is
starting to seem more and more like a
Barbra toast type villain somebody that
might be from a different reality
they're just trying to push their will
on people in this reality if you haven't
been reading Dark Knight's metal Barbra
tous is the big villain to that series
that's manipulating everyone but it will
be funny to see how he meshes with the
group I think if it goes well they will
try to bring him back more next season
but Constantine usually requires more
special effects so I think it just
depends on what they're gonna do with
their visual effects budget because
talking about firestorm now now that
they've lost Bo
haves a firestorm they need to put
somebody else back on the team on a more
permanent basis so I feel like
Constantine or Wally West could fill
that gap but over on the flash right now
there's still too much stuff for Wally
to help out with Barry's trial is coming
up so if there is any chance of Wally
West coming on Legends it probably
wouldn't be till later this season and
it would be just like a couple episode
arc and then if it really worked out
maybe they'd do it full-time in season
four we haven't seen a whole lot of
scenes with Barry explained to Wally why
you don't stick your bits in the
timeline I think Wally's just absorbed
that lesson over the course of season
three well I got trapped in the Speed
Force by avatar who was an evil Barry
maybe I don't mess with the timeline so
much but hopefully that explains what's
going on with the firestorm character
because II W had already confirmed that
Victor Garber was leaving the show we
knew about that that's why they killed
him off during the crossover so they
could be this big moment and a big
send-off for the character but then
after this episode e w published an
article saying that fronds jermay the
actor that plays Jax the other half of
firestorm was also leaving the show with
an option to come back if he ever wanted
to but the operative phrase is that he
was leaving the TV show so they are out
two characters and even though I do
think they have a few too many
characters on the show to do any one of
them that much service I think they need
a big upgrade because they got a whole
bunch of c-listers right now so we just
need somebody big like Wally West or
Constantine to come on a more permanent
basis I know a lot of you are pulling
for Wally to go on Titans I also feel
like that show already has too many
characters so if he does do that it
wouldn't be till a future season in the
way they're treating it right now is is
that it's relatively self-contained like
we got a teaser for the Robin suit so
they got to tell some backstory they got
to explain how the Titans come together
then maybe in a future season if they
want to cross the show's over then they
can bring Wally West on but they'll
explain a little bit more as they drop
more footage they'll be more behind the
scenes Titans stuff dropping in the next
couple weeks because they're filming the
first couple of episodes right now as we
speak I will totally do videos for those
two Constantine episodes when it comes
back in February but leave all your
bonus video requests in the comments
below
congratulations to the latest flash ring
giveaway winner at Kaos is coming please
private message me so I can get your
contact details
was a new round in this video I'll just
announce the winner the next time I post
DC but I got new Marvel posting soon you
can click here for my flash trailer to
learn all about the trial of the flash
and you can click here for brand new
Star Wars thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight